leader ed davey with us now proper
kicking what happened
well i think this will send shockwaves
through the british political system
this was uh liberal democrat victory is
one of our best ever
by-election victories and if it was
repeated across the south of england
literally dozens of conservative mps
would lose their seats to
the liberal democrats and you know we
were fighting on the doorstep and i came
here 16 times i talked to hundreds of
people we were finding they've been
taken for granted they feel
that the conservative party isn't
listening to them many of them aren't
very happy with boris johnson
and i think in areas like this it's
really clear that it's the liberal
democrats who can beat the conservatives
and
boy did we do that last night you
certainly did you absolutely transformed
30-point swing but
we both know we've both been in politics
a long time and
that's very rarely replicated in the
general election
well first of all it was a huge swing i
mean people talked about hartlepool
being a big swing this was more than
almost double hartlepool's swing to us
so this is absolutely huge
and i think people will need to take
notice of this
but also it actually builds on a trend
too in the local elections in the south
of england in places like oxfordshire
cambridgeshire hertfordshire surrey
wheelchair liberal democrats
made a quite big gains off for
conservatives so this is part of a trend
and i've been pointing out to people
that everyone's talking about the red
wall in the north
they should think about the blue wall
and it's that blue wall that liberal
democrats breached last night
we can knock it down in the south with
little democrats taking lots of seats
off the conservatives
i think there's been a growing swell
towards us in these sorts of areas
and so to last night while it was uh you
know i have to say
it was much better than i had expected
it was part of that trend
where libertarian cats are beating
conservatives across the south
it's it's a yellow brick in a blue wall
at this stage let's
let's uh let's not get ahead of
ourselves uh mr david but what i would
like to ask you is whether you entered
into
a pact with labour in order to transfer
tories last night
no we campaigned on liberal democrat
policies we campaigned on
our strong environmental record our
desire to make sure that uh planning
policy for example was a big issue here
is led by the community by people who
have a voice
rather than the conservatives
propositions which is to take power away
from people
and give it to developers you know
liberal democrats believe we need more
affordable homes greener homes
we need more homes for our young people
but the planning reforms being put
forward by the conservatives
would as teresa may said result in the
wrong homes
in the wrong places so you know that
planning reforms
uh then linked to our strong
environmental campaigning
i think is what uh tilts the balance for
many conservative voters
because there are many voters who net
always vote conservative
but last night they wrote a liberal
democrat and i think there's a trend
growing there so
there may be one yellow brick in the
wall uh as of last night there's many
more to follow
what's wrong with a lib lab packed ahead
of the next
general election um the tories of you
know
if one looks back i was looking back
earlier on uh this morning about how
many times the conservatives have been
in power as opposed to any other party
they trans all the rest so although
you're having your moment of glory today
what's wrong with having a lib lab
packed in order
to to be a a better opposition to uh the
government
well very different parties um little
democrats want a fairer greener more
caring
country but liberal democrats are mainly
um
fighting the conservatives so in the
south of england where we're
particularly strong in parts of london
uh actually in parts of some of the
suburbs in places like manchester
a place like hazel grove cheadle it's
the liberal democrats who are competing
against the conservatives and labour are
not very strong there
so it really wouldn't wouldn't help you
know liberal immigrants i believe
are recovering we are showing as a
result of last night
that we are the ones to beat the
conservatives in so many uh areas
and you know our message of campaigning
and talking to people
and we're great campaigners great
community politicians and because we
listen to people
they do feel uh that we respond to their
their concerns in the way that
conservatives increasingly aren't
uh i think many people certainly in
cheshire but i think across
the south of england feel the
conservatives almost forgotten them take
them for granted
and they feel ignored by them and
liberal democrats are filling that
vacuum
so ed how concerned are you about a
story uh on the front page of the times
this morning that says two and a half
thousand vips
are going to be allowed to come to the
united kingdom without having to
quarantine from uefa and fifa
to take part or witness watch
um spectate on the euro 2020s how can
that be fair
although i haven't read the story from
what you just said uh it does not sound
fair
at all and you know it's part of the way
this
conservative government operates there's
one rule for their friends
another rule for the rest of us you know
we saw that with dominic cummings didn't
we during the pandemic who
who broke all the rules and didn't pay
the price and you know so often with
this conservative government
uh if you're friendly with them you get
special favors that is not the way to do
politics
and actually here in cheshire and
amisham we did see a number of people
really cross with boris johnson feel
that he and his government aren't just
out of touch
but they're just listening to developers
who give them lots of money they're
listening to the people who who got huge
amounts of money through contracts
during the pandemic
there's a dissatisfaction with boris
johnson which i don't think the polls
have yet picked up but we were picking
up here on the doorsteps in cheshire
and i think that's one of the reasons
why the liberal democrats had such a
good victory here
fantastic win for you by any measure
sired um
what you're going to have is your
celebratory breakfast three shredded
wheat
you know i haven't thought about
breakfast i've been talking to uh
people in the media um but you know
we're going to have a celebration
obviously because it's such a big win
you know it's not often that you get a
30 swing i mean i i've got to look at
the history books i think it's the
biggest ever
uh liberal democrat by-election victory
which i think speaks uh volumes
i think it says that you know where we
go out and campaign i came here 16 times
to this by-election talk to hundreds of
people
where we talk to people people listen to
us like our message
and our see how different we are from
the conservatives
and i think we're going to keep plugging
away with our message of a fairer
greener more caring country
we're going to be plugging away and
saying look you know if you want the
homes to be affordable to be
green uh and the homes for young people
there's a different approach from the
conservatives
and i think messages like that okay in
areas like this
will resonate and i think liberal
democrats can win many many more seats
off the conservatives
see i was just looking for a flip up
one-liner but you were a politician
right through to the tape weren't you
sir
thanks very much indeed for joining us
this morning thanks a lot